thank you
[Music]
Adam Dell he's a partner at Goldman
Sachs his brother is the founder of Dell
oh [__] oh wow well lucky him yeah this
is a smart guy he's also in business
he's very successful uh so he's doing
business with somebody online he's
working on this like project video that
he has to send to a junior staffer to
like send out to someone else or
something he didn't realize that his
camera was still filming after he was
done with the thing that he was talking
about you're in computers dude it
doesn't say exactly what he did but we
know we did is it one of these yeah he
did the Randy Couture dude that's the
Randy Couture why is that the Randy's
tour you ever seen that video there's a
person walking down his chest no he's
jerking off yeah that's what I'm saying
that's what I'm saying but he didn't
know no he knew he was he was jerking
off wait where was he jacking
America baby what do you mean no I mean
like in this situation he started
jacking off like this like if this was
his thing yeah but he thought he had
already like uh stopped it like but but
what was he doing before jacking off
Adam he just had a meeting he had a
meeting so he just got up went into the
bathroom and started beating away I
don't think he left he just jacked off
right then and there he used the same
window he hung up on zoom and then right
then and there control and so he starts
doing his thing in his meeting he had
his pants around his ankles
he might have been prepping during the
vehicle yeah he was just like getting
ready like all right yeah yeah okay
Friday yeah see the P L's for that
all right thank you I saw like a similar
did this I don't know if it's the same
video teacher guy
oh is it a teacher guy oh I saw I saw a
thing where a guy didn't know he's like
prepping yeah yeah he would like to take
the tissue and take the lotion that's
the the people in the conference the
girl was like hey Justin Justin you're
still on and I think he turned off the
the sound so he couldn't hear oh
signing off
so yeah there's no real details about
anything because obviously like so much
stuff is redacted but basically it's to
be imagined that that's kind of what
happened so what what he did is he sends
the entire file of what was recorded oh
including that so it's like it's like a
thing where you like hit the thing and
it'll just send the thing yeah but he
didn't realize how to record last part
the junior staffer received it and then
he realized that's fast transition
that's in there so uh as soon as you
press okay see ya
that's all that's really fast I don't
know if that's not what he did that's
what it sounds like this is I don't
really know there's a million different
programs it could have been on that
maybe it didn't work out is this guy
over the age of 55
that sounds fun you still jacking off
after 55. well I like to believe after
his meeting he turned on uh Usher on his
Winamp
put some
nice and slow
and he's like oh yeah
jack off material yeah dude he had to
pay her
um millions of dollars in a settlement
just one person yeah it was one because
it went to a junior staff
um and then uh what if he was just
trying to show her a good time honest
mistake yeah
here's the thing
to all of us that is the story we get do
we believe that oh no I believe that he
sent it to her as you like what you see
baby holla back did he wink at the
camera
and then she goes I'll Raise You Like
You Raised yourself
[Laughter]
like Chong Lee from Bloodsport
round one fight
it uh so he ends up leaving that company
on good terms itself that's good thank
God and she leaves the company as well
on wonderful terms then he should come
back
so why both of us leaving yeah one of us
what if they both left to Apple and now
they're both working at Apple weird and
she catches them jacking off again but
because they're apple he is the bitmoji
thing so he's like he's like octopus the
captain always fights
Davey Jones
David Jones will always change it
you're stupid
such a weird ass thing to say but yeah
the funny thing is like so the way that
we're analyzing it now and even the way
I'm telling you it has no suspicions in
it it's very cut and dry like oh this
happened on accident it was an oopsie he
had to pay her that's it yeah good deal
but isn't that like
so convenient that this could just be in
another form the thing that everybody's
doing where they go you like what you
see like he said
it's just different because no nobody
wants to see a guy jerking are we
reading the clean version of that are we
reading the corporate that's true why
would they do that why would he record
the whole conference first that's what
I'm saying that's why I think it's
honest mistake and it just happens to be
a multi-millionaire and he's not like a
Radio Shack manager where you can't swim
for a bajillion dollars you know but
also too like I just feel like radio
[__] all the videos of of guys getting
caught jerking off while they're on like
Zoom call it's always guys who are like
50 and up dude because they're
technology dumb you don't know how to
use it it's just like or it's just like
a mishap cookies man yeah bro like yeah
exactly windows open yeah because when
you do the the zoom recording right you
[__] hit the yeah uh record the
meeting
yeah you may just forget that it's on
well it's just like my biggest moral of
the story here that I'm like I wish when
I'm over 55 I hope I'm still jacking off
to porn me too he's vigorous he's a very
vigorous thorough man you just can't
jerk off on laptops anymore dude you
can't no who does that anymore anyway
you [__] nerd you use a phone Dell oh
yeah
what if you're on a big screen you know
you get an iPad then you go to your
[__] living room you rich guy yeah
you blow it up if you want a 70 inch
experience
[Laughter]
OLED dudes I need a curved monitor if
you have it on your TV what if your
neighbor walks by like oh [__] no I rent
out a movie theater
projector guy you pull out the screen
and you're like okay perfect can you
heat up the the [__] projector
wasn't that a thing where people would
watch porn at movie theaters it's a
great experience why would you allowed
to jack off really that's your Pee-wee
Herman I think don't they have that now
like they have a like leaders yeah but
then why would you go there because
there's look because there's
conveniently placed holes in the wall oh
really those are called glory holes I
don't know I've never been to what else
oh just in case you guys didn't know for
all the younger viewers out there I went
into a um I accidentally walked into a
trans brothel really yeah wait so every
recently it's all trans
a lot of the members were
the members yes so like um so members
only type of thing I thought it was like
uh like a sex shop
slash smoke shop and a video store
that's ultimately what draw drew you in
there I need to get some condoms
because it was next to a place I was
getting tacos from oh and then I was
like how convenient oh right okay I
don't want to get protection for later
it's very considerate maybe some lube
yeah what else maybe some I don't know
like a outfit or something for me and
her okay Batman for me bad girl for her
whatever what's the sexy Batman version
so I I walked inside yeah and I was like
someone in the comments will answer him
that's sexy right that's all you need
before you continue you got any other he
just wanted to imagine me in the sexy
outfit a boy can't drink
it's for the man not the woman yeah I go
with Pro Master wife for us
inappropriate there's like it looks like
like a normal sex novelty store okay
yeah but very sparse items so I was like
you guys don't have that much inventory
what kind of [__] store is this
the person behind the cam uh the the
counter is trans right uh and then uh
and then they're like can I help you
hunt it and then I was like like female
presenting but male biological male
biological yeah and then I was like oh
yeah I'm looking for this and this and
they're like oh yeah we keep it behind
here and then like I was like okay I'm
just keep looking around and I'm like
man this stuff is Dusty it looks like
they haven't sold it in ages and I was
like looking back and they had these two
corners you go through and they're um
they call them like video rooms oh yeah
oh and then I'm in a industrial Trucking
neighborhood
and then I noticed like guys kept coming
in but they went straight through the
hall to these like viewing rooms and
then I just thought oh maybe you know
they're just truckers that want to go
and jack off real quick and then leave
right
that's what they do this guy doesn't own
any truckers I don't know maybe they
don't want to jack off
or don't know but they're they were they
were like man change of scenery dude
you're on the road all the time there's
there's Macho men like just walking in
truckers you know like cookies
Macho Macho I want to be a macho Macho
like yeah like straight up mechanics
[__] electrician like guys with their
butt crack showing and like muscle dudes
right love it they're coming in
going straight into the little Hall all
this and I'm just like damn like that's
interesting so I get my stuff and I'm at
the counter and then this uh guy like a
man
not presenting woman but in a schoolgirl
outfit runs outside comes to the counter
give me some condoms I need some condoms
grab some condoms runs back in and I'm
like oh [__] and I'm thinking
these guys
those guys in the club in the school
girl clothes yeah
that's that's happening yeah and that's
what I that's where I made the
connection this is a front this is a
this is a fake place did you end up
buying the condoms though I got my stuff
were they all expired yeah
they're all old right nope I had my
paper
bags ago walking out like yeah and then
guys are coming out another guy came out
with the with the with another
female presenting male with a with the
[__] me boots and then the outfit
and he's sweating and [__] and all the
time you're standing there silently
going yeah
find my things you know and then like
and then I'm just walking out and then
I'm just like
just processing what I just saw and I'm
like I think that was an undercover
brothel where they can you know get they
can have sex with ladyboys yeah it's
okay yeah
I I don't know that was super good
because at least
I think the [__] and
they were very like they look like women
yeah
yeah they dude they just look like some
of the guys had long hair like me and
balding like that and then they had a
school girl outfit on
and then like some of the yeah the guy
behind me
I feel like if they had money they could
be like really packed you could have it
all yeah but I was in a poor
neighborhood but the guys that were
having sex with the with the with the
ladyboys the customers yeah
it could have been them
oh like it was like you know what I mean
like it was like it looked like a
trucker with long hair now are you
absolutely sure that those weren't just
fitting rooms and it was them
and they were just trying clothes on and
coming back condoms because that's where
you try condoms oh like it's like a like
a like a cross-dressing fun time thing
like what if those were those guys but
he was asking for Condoms though that's
what guys yeah yeah do these fit they
don't fit and they're sweaty coming out
the sweaty coming out the
um you got a juice box thing
electrolytes now
the school girl that ran out and asked
for condoms and ran back in yeah that
told me every day I needed to know it
was an energy you could feel it we're
about to [__] we need some condoms
no but that's the end of the energy you
can feel that Vibe is this in here in
L.A
yeah is it in uh Commerce City of
Industry it's City of Industry oh I
don't like that it only took me two
tries
thank you
foreign